[Music]
chuck we're back
all right i couldn't stay away
well yes i got some more explaining to
do you got some explanatory oh my god i
sound like my mother-in-law
that's crazy or ricky ricardo one of the
other
well my mother-in-law is ricky ricardo
so i just i thought i had some more
things to say about
the rotation of the earth really yeah
well we did
we did something about what would happen
if it stopped
we did something about what how many
people superman would kill
right if you move backwards and stop the
earth if he flew backwards slowed down
the earth stopped it reversed it
stopped it again and sent it back yeah
nobody left
on earth as if that would actually
reverse time though
right as if right right as if so even if
it did
and could he still killed seven billion
people
okay or however many people were on
earth the year of that movie which i
think was 1970
in the seven late seventies yeah no then
i was old
so here you go you've heard of this
thing called centrifugal force
right the thing that makes you sort of
fly off because somebody
spun something around and things fly off
it's what keeps bucket in the water when
you do the whole
windmill it sounds like you've done some
experiments good if you
want to take water in a bucket a bucket
of water you can even with a cup of
water
if you take it and if you if you spin it
sort of fast enough
like like a windmill style then the
water will not come out
right even though you it was upside down
and if you ever played matchbox cars
where the car goes upside down and then
comes out the other side
you need sufficient centrifugal force
to keep the thing up against the track
i don't okay i was a hot wheels guy by
the way you were okay oh yeah i'm a hot
wheels guy i know you said matchbox
i get it sorry it was hot wheels that
had the loop to loose excuse me
forgive my my okay then the track was
yellow and it pieced together i remember
the whole thing
yes and it made for a great way to like
slap the
bottom of a friend it's like you take
that hot wheels track and you just
whack somebody oh oh oh oh okay
so you had issues as a child okay
that's another show we'll have you get
them out okay
never occurred to me multiple years
kicked out of elementary school
all right so this it turns out there's
no such thing
as centrifugal force it's the word we
give
to this thing that feels like a force
operating on you if you are the water in
that bucket
or if you're in that amusement park
where i think they call it the cyclone
where you're sort of pinned against the
wall of it and it rotates
and you feel this pressure increase on
you
so what's happening is because you're
getting spun
you have an urge to fly off
at a tangent of that circle okay
that urge to fly off that is prevented
you will feel as a centrifugal force
okay okay so if in any moment
the walls just disappeared on the
cyclone
at is it called the cyclone whatever
that was called out of the fly i forget
the name of it but i do remember
i think i'm missing remember because
cyclone is the roller coaster at
right at coney island at coney island so
whatever that thing is we've all
done it right and if at any instant
while that's spinning the walls just
disappeared
you would just fly off at a tangent
everybody would just fly off
going in exactly the tangential
direction they were going
right at the moment the walls
disappeared okay
lawsuit lawsuit
damn truck you're so cynical chuck
so what the wall does is prevent that
from happening
and then you it feels as though there's
a force acting on you
and by the way that is the worst ride to
take if you get nausea
if you feel nausea on on amusement park
rides because
if you try to throw up the throw up will
get pinned to the back of your throat
you'd have to like turn your head
sideways and then the throw up goes
sideways onto the next person
so so it's i don't think we have a
problem here neil
i always notice that that ride always
had an extra smell
to it compared to other to other rides
so anyhow so this centrifugal force
you will feel it as though it's a real
force and so that's why we gave it a
name
all right and by the way coriolis force
is another fictitious force
it feels like it's a real force
operating but it's the product of other
things going on
the coriolis force turns storms into
clockwise
counterclockwise clockwise direction in
the north and clockwise in the south
in fact we'll we'll land there at the
end of this explainer
so what that means is if you're on earth
and earth is spinning
you ought to feel some centrifugal force
yay
you ought to now who would feel the most
centrifugal force on earth where would
you be
uh at this at the center like
at the equator at the equator okay now
of course we all
finish one rotation in 24 hours
however they're traveling a much bigger
distance to do so
okay they move the entire circumference
of the earth about 25
000 miles in one day whereas as you
approach santa claus on the north pole
your circle becomes
shorter and shorter so you are moving
slower and slower
okay okay and centrifugal so the people
at the people in ecuador should all have
their hands up just going
okay just like any good amusement park
ride
all the equator people all the
acquainted people
[Laughter]
so uh you get a photographer to take
your picture and sell it back to you at
the end of that
exactly so so the equator is about 25
000 miles around and it takes 24 hours
for one full rotation okay so if you
divide those two numbers you get
approximately
they're going approximately a thousand
miles an hour right okay
and that's fast i mean that's faster
than you would ever be going in anything
in your life
that's right okay now you don't feel
that
because first earth connects you to its
surface but also you're moving
very uniformly through space
to do so and the air around you is
moving with you
so it's not like air is coming past you
with the thousand mile that you feel oh
my gosh i'm in motion and i feel the
jiggle in the shake
by the way pre-galileo
people's arguments against earth's
motion
was if earth were turning and moving
we'd feel it
right okay why wouldn't you if you're on
a horse
and buggy you feel that all right
you feel the bumps and the wiggles and
the jiggles and even if the ride is
smooth you feel it
so clearly earth can't be moving we of
course we're not rotating either
everything is moving around us so it
wasn't just our ego
that supported the idea that we are in
the center of all things
at the center of wealth it's not just
what's happening with our ego
it kind of made sense when you thought
about it
okay right what they didn't realize is
that if you made things
smoother and smoother and smoother you
will feel the motion
less and less and less right so ask
anybody on an ocean liner when the ocean
liner
first pulls out from the port you don't
really notice that
and you look around you say wait a
minute why is the dock going by me
and you look at it and you realize
you're the one in motion
not the dock okay
and so the bigger the vessel sort of the
more stately is its movement
through space and time and the less you
notice its motion
so you know i i was once on a bus
on the tunnel going from paris to london
okay and this is a long tunnel that not
only goes under land but goes under the
english channel okay and so
um that is very well designed it's very
smooth so i'm in a bus
and that they drive the bus onto a car
and the car has no windows
onto a railroad car a car has no window
so i'm in there
and i feel it kind of move a little bit
but it's a slow acceleration and i think
it has very high
top speeds but i have no concept of this
okay now inflate this scenario to the
entire earth
okay you are moving a thousand miles an
hour as earth rotates
you are moving 18 what's the 18 miles
per second
in orbit around the sun and you don't
feel any of that
okay okay you don't feel anything so
here's my point
all right so the faster you rotate
okay the greater is the centrifugal
force you will
that will operate on you okay so let's
go back to
all the residents of ecuador which is
not the only country that straddles the
equator
okay in fact the equator goes entirely
through the middle of africa
for example all right so so
here we go you can ask
if it's trying to fling you off the
earth
okay but the force of gravity is
resisting back
by what force is it trying to fling you
off that upward
centrifugal force subtracts from the
gravitational force that the earth is
trying to put on you
it subtracts okay so chuck what do you
weigh here
here and now uh 192 pounds yeah
you used to be like 170 so 178
yeah and now i have a corona baby that
i'm pregnant with
corona i'm pregnant with a corona baby
all right i'll give you 190 pounds okay
okay so if you do the math
you run to ecuador because we're in the
western hemisphere so let's stay there
you run to ecuador you will not be 190
pounds
you'll be like 185 pounds what that's
how significant it is
that's if i if i had my math correct and
i think i did
there are pounds less that you weigh
for living on the equator than for
living anywhere else simply because
the spinning earth is trying to fling
you off
nice yes yes it's it's significant
so this concept how much do you weigh in
i just need a plane ticket
it changes your weight it won't change
your mass oh let's make that clear okay
sucks if you chubby on the equator
you're chubby everywhere
damn it now here's someone who does not
benefit from this
and that's of course santa claus because
as you
go from the equator and you go to
farther and farther north or south of
course this works the other way
uh and you go farther and farther away
from the equator the circle that you
travel is smaller each day
your speed is lower we're here in sort
of
40 degrees between 30 and 40 degrees
latitude
most of the population of the world
lives at that latitude
and north and south and
uh at this latitude we're going about
800 miles an hour
due east so that's slower than the
equator guess who's not moving
sideways at all has no sideways velocity
it's santa claus on the north pole
all he's doing is sort of rotating like
this but he's not getting flung
so if you weigh santa claus on the north
pole
that is his authentic earth weight oh
sweet okay which is only 322 pounds
it's all them cookies and milk
actually he's skinny as a rail during
the summer yes
as as my seven-year-old told me this
year
santa claus can't exist i went really
why not
she said nobody could eat all those
cookies without becoming a diabetic
oh there we don't know whether he's a
diabetic plus it'll be a fun
sort of sci-fi film if he gets thin over
the summer gets
on the sleigh and he's skinny on the
sleigh but every stop he makes it gets a
little fatter
and then the reindeer say we can't do it
we can
we gotta land this trip i'm done
that's pretty good or or he or he gets
stuck in the chimney
right at some point you're not fitting
down the chimney that's all i'm saying
that's true so you can ask the question
at what speed
must earth rotate so that the
centrifugal force
exactly balances the gravitational
weight that you'd otherwise have
you might ask that question i just did
through you
right now
so if you spin earth faster and faster
and faster
right you weigh less and less and less
and less so this chuck 190 pounds 185
180 170 150 100
50. there's a point where you will weigh
zero
and you'll just hover over the equator
standing there
do you know what speed that is i'll tell
you
okay if earth rotates once every hour
and a half
damn okay now that's fast
but think about it think about it okay
if we rotate once every hour and a half
and you're just floating there above the
earth
you are actually in orbit around the
earth
that's right okay do you know how long
it takes
the space station to make one orbit
around the earth
let me guess 90 minutes ah
i you didn't let me guess oh sorry
sorry there we go wait wait wait watch
this
90 minutes
so of course it's a couple hundred miles
up so it's a little longer but basically
it's in the 90 minute zone
okay earth surface up to low what we
call low earth orbit leo
low earth orbit it all happens in about
90 minutes so you can recover what
happens in orbit by spinning the earth
so fast
that everyone on the equator weighs zero
and that happens right when we complete
one rotation
in basically an hour but i think if you
do the math it's 88 minutes but
wow good good for these purposes so
that's just kind of a fun fact about the
rotation of the earth i think that is
really cool i mean so you could actually
that's like super low earth orbit
yes and you don't have to worry about
ducking the trees
because everybody with you is also
orbiting exploding
is also floating that's right i left out
something earth is slightly flattened
at the poles and slightly wider at the
equator we might have said this on
another explainer
so we're oblate we're sort of hamburger
shaped rather than prolate
which would be hot dog shaped stretched
pole to pull where
we're flattened at the equator so
everyone on the equator is
farther away from the center of the
earth than people living on the poles
people and penguins living near the
poles if you're farther away from
earth's center the force of gravity on
you is less
so already their
weight is less just because earth is
bulbous at the equator relative to the
poles
then you throw in the rotation on top of
it folks on the equator
got it made in the shade well watch out
atkins diet coming
it's a new keto diet it's a new keto
diet this super low earth
orbit diet earth orbit does super low
again
diets are so that you lose mass not that
you lose weight oh yeah
that's just to make that clear forget
that and chuck one last thing i said
coriolis force was another sort of
fictitious force
so air pockets going north from the
equator
overtake the land that they find
themselves over
because it was going sideways faster
than the new place it finds itself okay
so it overtakes it
air pockets moving due south
find themselves on land that's moving
faster than they are
than they used to be so what happens is
if you have a low pressure system
air from above it ends up coming in
behind it and that creates a
general circulation that is
counterclockwise
for all storms and nearly all tornadoes
okay there's some exceptions but it
requires extraordinary
circumstances to counter balance that so
all storms in the northern hemisphere
rotate counterclockwise if you sped
up earth you increase
the coriolis forces and then you
have ferocious storms
such as what's happening on jupiter ah
okay jupiter is way bigger than earth
yeah but it's you know 10 times across
okay you can fit like 10 earths across
the width of jupiter something like that
maybe eight earths and jupiter rotates
twice as fast as earth does oh
there it is so jupiter had the great red
spot oh the beautiful red spot it is a
storm
and it's been raging for more than at
least 300 years
okay so so these are the consequences of
it's a weather man's
uh
happy place yes i was gonna say yes the
weathermen will always have a job
on jupiter that is a weather man's dream
just like that a 300-year storm
yeah i'm never i'll never be fired
i've got a lifetime job i shall chuck we
got to call it quits there
all right all right always good to have
you man always good to be here
we're done here i've been your host neil
degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist and as
always keep looking up